>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Richard Holmes is best known as
the world's preeminent biographer
of the romantic era poets.
He not only tells the tales of these
writers, he absorbs their lives.
He projects the romantic
sensibility.
His two volume biography
of Coleridge has been called
the near masterpiece of empathy.
But after studying the
romantic era for years,
Holmes realized something.
There was a powerful
largely overlooked influence
on the romantic culture and
on the writers of the time,
and that influence was science.
He explores this theme in his
new book, The Age of Wonder:
How the Romantic Generation
Discovered the Beauty
and Terror of Science.
Holmes was born in
London and educated
at Churchill College Cambridge.
He began his career as a journalist.
For 20 years, he was
a feature writer
and a reviewer for the London Times.
His first book, Shelley: The
Pursuit, was published in 1974
and won the Somerset Maugham Prize.
That was followed by his
first volume on Coleridge.
Next came an account of the
friendship between Samuel Johnson
and the poet Richard Savage.
He's also written two
volumes of memoirs focusing
on the craft of biography.
One reviewer has described
his latest, The Age of Wonder,
as a big hearted river of a
book in which the twin engines
of scientific curiosity and poetic
invention pulsate on every page.
In Holmes' view, romantic era
scientist and poets shared a vision.
Both held to the hope
for human improvement.
Coleridge believes that
science had a poetic side
because it too had
a passion for hope.
Some observers believe Holmes'
newest book has a lesson
for us today.
It can serve as a model for bringing
the sciences and the arts together
so we can all grasp the beauty
and terror of modern life.
Holmes might agree for he has said
scientific breakthrough's promised
benefits but also raised fears.
It was such in the romantic
era and it is still today.
Please join me in welcoming
Richard Holmes.
[ Applause ]
>> I would just like to
introduce Suzy [phonetic],
who is our signer today.
[ Applause ]
>> It's a great pleasure to be here.
I've just flown in from London.
Why I'm the only man in
the tent wearing a suit?
[ Laughter ]
>> I probably will take
it off later on, right?
And I'm tremendously grateful
to two major institutions,
of course the Library of Congress,
which I want to say something about,
and also the Washington Post which
I want to say something about.
But there's a third institution and
this requires me to put this hat on.
And you can't read it but it
says Junior League of Washington,
and they are the young ladies who
at the signing in have been looking
after you in the hats,
the white and black hats,
and they've just elected
me the only male member
of the Junior League of Washington.
[ Applause ]
>> And the point about them,
you-- many of you will know,
they do wonderful work
helping people challenged
in their reading abilities
of all ages, alright.
And they go fund gathering.
And if you want to help them,
go straight on to the net.
It's jlw.com and make a
contribution because that is one
of the major themes as I
understand at the festival, books,
reading, helping people to read.
So that's JLV-- the JLW.
I have to say, I had a certain
disappointment arriving here
in Washington because I
understood that it was traditional
that the rain poured down.
You probably-- some of you wish
the rain was pouring down, alright,
but it was-- I had a special
joke arranged for this
which I'm gonna tell anyway,
alright, which has to do
with writing and some of you may
have been to the big festival
in England, in Wales, in fact
the Hay-on-Wye Literary Festival,
and there traditionally
also the rain pours down.
So to get to the tent, you
have to wade through mud, okay,
and this was happening to me 2,
3 years ago and just as I got
to the tent, remember this is Wales,
a voice called out and you'll have
to do this with a Welsh accent,
"fine weather for biographers."
[ Laughter ]
>> And then he added,
"plenty of feet of clay."
[ Laughter ]
>> Very, very true.
So, nonetheless I'm very
glad that it's shining today.
I wanted to say this about the
Library of Congress which is one
of your great national institutions.
For the first time, I had
a chance to get to see it,
and one of the things I came
away with was the Jefferson,
the Thomas Jefferson Library.
It's so impressive
partly because it's small.
It's not too monumental.
It's possible to have it in
probably a room and a half.
And Jefferson organized his library
under three headings,
not Dewey organization.
He organized it under memory,
reason, and imagination.
And I thought about
this and I thought
that roughly defines the
task of a writer like me.
For memory, we are going
back into history to discover
and particularly the history
of science in this case.
Reason, we try to understand
and explain the science
that has been done in the past.
And imagination, we try
to bring it to life.
So for me, there is Jeffersonian
concept, memory, reason,
imagination, very, very important.
When I arrived at customs
and immigration,
the officer looked very carefully at
me and then said, "Professor Holmes,
what is the purpose of your visit?"
Now, have you understood this right?
The purpose of your visit.
This seems to me like a
metaphysical question.
Like, what is the purpose
of the universe,
and I hardly noticed him stamping
my thing and sending me out, okay.
And so in a way, that's
what I want to talk
about this very few
minutes the purpose
of the visit, the purpose
of writing.
I've been steady.
I was told that I should spend 20
minutes not talking about my book
and then 10 minutes
answering questions
about not talking about my book.
So, we'll see how we
get on with that.
So, I thought I'd do this
in this shape of form.
I'm going to use questions.
People have actually asked me in
very the brief time I've been here,
and the first one was, "Mr. Holmes,
did you come from London
by hot air balloon?"
It's on [inaudible] with
the cover of the book
to which my quick answer was,
well, the first hot air balloon
across the atlantic from England to
America was described by none other
than Edgar Allan Poe in
the New York Sun in 1844.
Three English pilots, including
the famous Charles Green,
and they overflew Greenland and
they landed on the shore somewhere,
I think in Massachusetts.
This was the biggest scoop
the New York Sun had ever had.
And then Edgar Allan Poe
realized and revealed
that it was a complete hoax.
They had never crossed the Atlantic.
It was the first of
his stories of mystery
and imagination that was in 1844.
But the first person who
flew the English Channel,
it was an English balloon
but the pilot was an
American, Dr. John Jeffries.
So that's a little bit of
history which appears in my book.
And the first woman aeronaut
was an actress, Mrs. Sage
and she has a great
comic turn in my book.
And at the end of this
week coming, I'm going--
so it's maybe the last
you ever see of me,
to the international balloon fiesta
in New Mexico to fly with the winner
of the American hot
air challenge cup.
Bye-bye. [Laughter] Second question,
can you remember your
long subtitle, alright.
In fact, it's amazing.
I just noticed it's not on
the cover of the book, okay.
Anyway, the long subtitle is how the
romantic generation discovered the
beauty and terror of science,
and that is in a way
my first serious point
because this is a history of
age in the century of science
that the notion that science is
both beautiful and threatening
and menacing is a key
idea to grasp and one
that we have absolutely inherited.
>> And one of the themes of my book
is to see how this began in Europe
and in England in the
late 18th century.
I'll give you one example of
this, that there's a passage
or chapter describing the
invention of the minus safety lamp
which I'm sure some
of you [inaudible]
by the chemist Humphry Davy,
a brilliant piece of invention
which I tried to describe which
prevented the deep mine explosions
of methane, a beautiful
invention benefit to mankind.
But what happened?
As a result of that lamp minus,
we're sent deeper and deeper
into the minds and gradually
the casualties grew again.
So it's a double-edged sword,
and that would be an example.
There are others, but that's
just one for the book.
Question, would you describe
your book differently
to a science graduate
or an arts graduate?
To a science graduate, I would say
this book weighs 9.958 kilograms.
It's 5 centimeters thick.
It's 485 pages long.
It's got 72 footnotes and it's
got 306 lines of poetry in it
which is the point I
began to look skeptical.
How would I describe
it to an arts graduate?
Well, I'd say this
is a group biography
and it takes a particular period
between Captain Cook's first
navigation of the globe, 1768,
and Charles Darwin
setting out in 1831,
famous voyage to the
Galapagos Island.
So it's that period
of time about 60 years
and it emphasizes the friendship and
the contact and the letter writing
and the inspiration that moved
between literary writers and poets
and the scientists of the period.
Now, sometimes people
say, are you sure?
Are you sure about this?
Then we'll give you one single
proof and I want to read a poem.
I promised my self I'll read a
poem, and this-- let me set it up.
First of all, it's by a woman poet,
and this is again a very
important theme of the kind
of history I'm writing because I
think that women have been written
out the history of science certainly
in the 18th and 19th century,
and I think there's a
lot of recovery to do.
And this poem is by Anna
Barbauld and she was working
as an assistant to Joseph Priestley.
As you know, his laboratory
was burnt down and he came here
to the land of the free, it's
Philadelphia, and he worked there
for the finer years of his life.
This was when he was
still in England
and he was doing experiments
with a vacuum.
Some of you may have
seen the famous picture
by Joseph Reiter Darby [phonetic]
which is a bird fluttering
in a big glass vacuum tube
and the idea was to experiment
with what was the mysterious
gas in the tube
that kept the bird, the dove alive.
And Priestley in fact was
on the trail of oxygen.
He used all kinds of
animals and one was a mouse.
So he had laboratory mouse.
And Anna Barbauld began to
worry not so much about oxygen
but about the mouse
and so she wrote a poem
which was called the Mouse's
Petition to Dr. Priestley found
in the cage where he had
been confined all night
by which we understand the
mouse, not Dr. Priestley.
So you have to imagine that just
like today, experimental cage,
this mouse was scheduled to undergo
the oxygen test the following day,
and when Priestley came
down, he found this poem.
I just wanna quote a
couple of lines from this.
And this is Anna Barbauld who
was very well read in science
but suddenly putting herself in the
place of a non-volunteering mouse.
And this is what the mouse
says to the scientist.
For here forlorn and sad I sit
within the wiry grate and tremble
at the approaching morn
which brings impending fate.
The cheerful light, the vital
air of blessings widely given,
let nature's commoners enjoy
the common gifts of heaven.
The well thought philosophic mind
to all compassion gifts and cast
around the world an equal eye
and feels for all that lives.
So there is possibly the first
animal rights poem, alright.
And very interestingly, it came
out of this scientific laboratory
in 18-- 1773, and that's just
one tiny example of the thing
that happens throughout my
book, and what interest me
so much is the connection
between the writer--
the literary writer
and the scientist.
Question, why did you
change after writing--
after waiting for 40 years
on literary biography
to science biography?
I felt there was a slight tone
of reproach in that question.
Why did-- why did you do that?
The quick answer is I'd written
about the poet Samuel
Taylor Coleridge,
the one who took the opium,
you remember Kubla Khan,
and it turned out that
as a young man,
his great friend was Humphry Davy
who is gonna be the greatest chemist
of the age and become
president of the Royal Society.
And I discovered when Davy was
experimenting with a new kind
of gas, nitrous oxide, which
is also called laughing gas,
he called for volunteers
and amazingly among them,
hot from his opium experiments,
was the 24-year-old
Samuel Taylor Coleridge.
So you have to imagine, the
scientist and the poet breathing
in the nitrous oxide and
then dancing, knocking people
over in the street, writing
poetry under the influence.
It's all there in the book and
it's there in the notebooks.
So that friendship made me think if
that's Coleridge and Davy, the poet
and the scientist, maybe there's
a much bigger story there.
So, that was one of the
things that set me off.
I should also say I
had an amazing chance
when I started to write this book.
I got a summer fellowship at
Trinity College, Cambridge
and that is Trinity is the
great-- it's Newton's College.
It's the great scientific
college in England.
And it-- there you-- when you
dine, I was there for 6 months,
you just sit anywhere on the table,
okay, that that long table is
in their place, you don't know
who you're gonna sit next to.
And I have to say in
the time I was there,
there were six Nobel Prize winners
and I sat next to each of them
and it was very interesting
to try and ask some questions.
And one of the things I found is
that unlike many literary
professors,
the scientists loved explaining
things and they were really good
at doing it, and that was something
that fascinated me, converted me,
and now let me give you one
pure example of this that I sat
down one evening next to a Russian
mathematician who spoke no English
at all and the one thing I knew is
that he knew about Evariste Galois,
the great romantic mathematician.
So that was the one
thing I turned to him.
I said, Evariste Galois, and
this wonderful smile spread
across his face and then
he leaned across the table
and managed this college
table with all the silverware,
alright, don't you think?
And he drew all the silverware
over him and he began to lay
out an algebraic box with the
knives and the forks and the pepper
and he explained without using any
words, Evariste Galois' theory.
It cost chaos, the waiters had to
come and intervene in the end, okay,
but-- [Laughter] And that was just
one example and that changed me.
I thought this is something
to meet people like that.
It's something I must write about.
Question, are scientists
madder than poets?
The answer is it's fully
[inaudible] my book.
The answer is no and yes sir.
And that story William and
Caroline Herschel, again,
I emphasized Caroline Herschel, two
astronomers, brother and sister,
a kind of William and
Dorothy Wadsworth
of astronomy is extraordinary,
very passionate,
very interesting relationship,
full of ups and downs
and extraordinary exchanges.
Caroline became the first really
efficient woman astronomer
of the period, in fact
got a government pension,
and she did a wonderful thing.
She kept a journal just
like Dorothy Wadsworth
of William Herschel's observations
and they are there in the archive
and it's something
I was able to use.
I have to say the first page,
they were both from Hannover.
It was written in German.
I thought my luck was out.
And then from then
on, as she was working
in England, she wrote in English.
So their story shows a kind of
passion which I would certainly
as bright and strong as
anything of the poets.
>> Question, did you
get any fan letters?
Well, I got a fan letter from
NASA and they pointed out that
in the footnote on page 295 where
I described the Hubble telescope,
I had got one figure
9.91 percent out.
But as it referred to the cost of
the Hubble, they were not pleased.
[Laughter] I also-- I had a
wonderful former fan letter
which is relevant now from
Harold Varmus who is the--
a Nobel Prize winner in medicine
who's gonna be talking initially
after me in another tent who said
that he'd recommended my book
to the freshmen of Amherst College,
and the result is I think it broke
the bank because the department had
to buy 459 copies of it, alright.
And so that's the kind of fan
that you really like, alright.
Special story telling methods.
Yes. One is to keep to
length and to keep to time
which I'm rapidly running out
from, but let me describe one thing
in the book is the use
of the vertical footnote.
Everybody ask me what's
a vertical footnote?
The main body of the story you
tell is in chronological time
but continually, you want to
drop out of that time and go back
to what happened before or go
forward to see the influence,
hence a footnote which
describes the Hubble telescope.
So that's one technique in a way
that I thought I pioneered slightly
in using literary methods
to describe scientific
effects, the vertical footnote.
What are you going to write next?
I don't have to answer
that question.
So that rapidly moves us on to the
tenth and the last and this is this.
I think I got two [inaudible].
The other institution
that is responsible
for me being here is the Washington
Post which I have huge respect for,
and they asked this question
which is a serious one.
Can writers change the world?
And I just want to
finish with the draft
of the piece I sent in
the blog about this.
I have a literary Irish aunt,
a fiery fan of James Joyce,
who once dismissed this
question with a snort
of derision signed in Irish.
[Laughter] Writers don't
have to change the world.
Sure, it's changing
fast enough anyway.
They should try and
slow it down instead
or maybe make it go backwards.
So considering this response, I've
slightly reformulated the question,
when did people stop
believing that writers could
or should change the world.
Because up to the mid
19th century in Europe,
this was an automatic assumption,
part of the enlightenment project
central to the idea of progress.
Knowledge is power
said Francis Bacon.
In 1820, the poet Shelley
who I've written
about could still hopefully
say poets and philosophers
of the unacknowledged
legislators of the world.
So I have to tell you the late poet
W.H. [inaudible] Auden said, well,
that makes writers sound rather like
secret policemen, okay [inaudible].
But Shelley's exact contemporary,
Humphry Davy who I've mentioned,
he put a different view and this is
something I want to leave you with.
It wasn't writers but
maybe it was the scientists
who are changing the world and he
said, if you compared Shakespeare
or Francis Bacon, Milton or Newton,
who do you think had
changed the world more?
Very interesting question and
I think there is an answer now
which says from the 20th century
with penicillin, air travel,
and nuclear power, 21st
century mobile phone, internet,
planet change, et cetera, that
might be the proper response.
But then, I think writers
have inherited a new form
of this question.
Is it changed for the
better or for the worse?
Is our world the kind we want
or the kind we should have
or the kind we have foolishly lost?
Do we have reasons to hope or to
fear, to dream and wonder or simply
to laugh at the absurdity
of the whole thing?
By posing such questions and
exploring all possible answers,
writers are no longer
asked to change the world.
They are asked continually
to re-imagine it,
which is a far more radical request.
But I'm not sure that my Joycean
aunt would approve all the same.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> I think we got time for
just a couple of questions.
Are there any in the romantic
generation net today you believe
would be or could be or
should be scientifically,
clinically categorized as
manic-depressive, bipolar,
schizophrenic, and/or in some
other category of mental illness?
>> Okay. I guess there has been a
whole thesis written about this,
the mental or bipolar thing
of writers or scientists.
My answer to that would be no,
but what is very, very noticeable
with someone like Davy
or the Herschels
or Mungo Park explorer is
a kind of recklessness,
a passionate recklessness that they
would push and sacrifice themselves
to find the truth to
pursue their science.
I give you one example from
Davy and you can tell me
if you think this is
manic-depressive or not.
When he was testing those gases,
they didn't know what they were,
he inhaled carbon monoxide.
It is one now used
for committing suicide
in the car and the backyard, okay.
That gas, they didn't
know it, and he inhaled it
and he virtually killed himself.
He came back and he re-inhaled it
and he wrote as he was breathing,
his pulse rate, his visionary
distortions and this note,
I do not think I shall die.
Now, what kind of extremism is that?
And that happens again and again
at this period and it's a kind
of recklessness with which I
think science has still driven.
So that's my slightly
depressive answer.
I reckon we've got-- have
we got one more minute?
One more minute, one more question.
Sir.
>> I'd be interested in
your view of Stephen Hawking
as scientist and as popular writer.
His new book is selling like
hot cakes here and in England
and I'd be interested
in your reaction to him.
>> Okay. You should have
asked that 25 minutes ago.
Very good question.
Okay. The new book is
called The Grand Design
and it's become controversial
partly because it sounds
like an atheist track, alright.
That's one of the problems there.
This is what I'd say
about that book.
It's a problem that begins
in the 19th century that more
and more science is expressed
in terms of pure mathematics,
and pure mathematical
setups are very difficult
to imagine or visualize.
And when you get to string theory
or M-theory, it is very difficult
to know, is the scientist
speculating
or is it something
that can be proved?
And I think that's a
very, very big dilemma
and I just finally add one
more thing very important
which I call displacement, and
this bare on the two cultures.
One of the things that's happened
since Copernicus removed the earth
from the center of the solar
system and said it was the sun,
science has displaced us more
and more in terms of time,
how small we are in terms of the
universe, how irrelevant we are
to a quantum universe, that is
to say they're very, very small,
and also to the very, very big, and
also in terms of time and evolution.
We seem to occupy a more
and more displaced space and
yet at the same time, we are
developing beautiful theories
and we are writing
and we are here today.
And I think there is the division
between the science
culture displacing us
and the literary culture trying
to put his back and put meaning
into everything around this.
There's the difference
and that's my time.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay. Very good.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.